[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans sens public
nous sommes le jeudi 25 mai nous sommes
ensemble pour 1h30 de débat et de
décryptage d'actualité avec aujourd'hui
beaucoup de voitures au programme on va
commencer par l'actualité du jour cette
cérémonie ce midi à Roubaix en hommage
aux trois policiers bord dimanche dans
un accident provoqué par un chauffard
comment en finir avec la délinquance
routière ce sera le thème de notre
premier débat je rappelle que plus de
3200 personnes ont trouvé la mort sur
les routes de France l'année dernière
qui veut encore des aides fe vous savez
ces zones à faible émission de pollution
mais visiblement pas Olivier Marleix le
fait que on est plus droit de rentrer
quand on est comme moi à bouger
d'Eure-et-Loir de rentrer avec une
voiture au gasoil dans Paris est-ce que
ça va empêcher le réchauffement de la
planète
alors interdire progressivement les
centres-villes aux véhicules les plus
polluants ça ressemblait à l'idée du
siècle sur le papier pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air et puis la santé des
citadins mais voilà plusieurs
agglomérations concernées mais
aujourd'hui les deux pieds sur le frein
alors pourquoi ça coince parce qu'on a
sous-estimé l'impact social économique
et puis comment améliorer le dispositif
ce sera le thème de notre second débat
mais tout de suite place à notre premier
thème avec ces tragédies auxquelles on a
assisté encore ce week-end sur les
routes en cause les comportements
irresponsables qui tuent ça ce sont les
mots prononcés par Emmanuel Macron ce
midi à Roubaix devant l'école de police
pour rendre hommage aux trois policiers
morts en intervention ce week-end le
chauffard qui les a percutés roulés à
grande vitesse il avait bu il avait fumé
du cannabis drogue et alcool au volant
faut-il durcir la loi c'est un sujet de
Nadia Lorjou
trois policiers tués dans le Nord par un
automobiliste alcoolisé et drogué une
fillette de 6 ans morte attrape par une
conductrice sous l'emprise du cannabis
sans oublier la faire Palmade la
conduite en état d'ivresse ou sous
l'emprise de la drogue est un fléau en
atteste ces chiffres de la sécurité
routière la drogue est responsable d'un
accident mortel sur 5 1 sur 3 pour
l'alcool dans les deux situations en cas
de décès d'un tiers le conducteur
s'expose au minimum à une peine de 7 ans
de prison et 100000 euros d'amende pour
homicide un volontaire le terme homicide
routier serait plus approprié pour une
sénatrice LR qui a déposé une
proposition de loi dans ce sens faut pas
se cacher c'est un débat sur lequel nous
on travaillait notamment avec mon
collègue de la Somme Laurence saumon
parce que nous avions été chacun
sensibilité dans notre territoire moi au
sein des Alpes-Maritimes à Antibes ou un
jeune de 17 ans qui s'appelait Noé a été
percuté par un chauffard qui conduisait
sous l'emprise d'alcool et de
stupéfiants et qui 70 jours après la
détention provisoire a été libéré ce qui
est très dur pour les familles c'est
vraiment une sorte de double peine en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut vraiment
travailler à l'effectivité des peines et
à la plaque habilité c'est vraiment
l'objet de notre proposition de loi
plusieurs associations dénoncent le
laxisme des juges concernant la réelle
application des peines prononcées pour
elle il faut placer la sécurité routière
et la prévention au cœur des priorités
le col pénal et puis il faudrait aussi
prévenir et informer toute la population
parce qu'il y a pas que les jeunes
maintenant qui fument du cannabis ou qui
prennent autre chose et qui conduisent
faire des campagnes de prévention je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais sous
le le j'allais dire le règne mais c'est
pas le bon mot de Monsieur Macron on
s'occupe pas beaucoup de sécurité
routière sauf quand il y a eu l'accident
de palmal mais sinon on en parle pas je
crois qu'il faudrait reprendre un petit
peu les campagnes d'information et de
prévention parce que quand on passe son
permis de conduire je suis pas certaine
qu'on parle beaucoup ou des victimes et
des accidents mortels Gérald Darmanin
proposait en février dernier de
supprimer directement les 12 points du
permis de conduire en cas de
consommation de drogue au volant ce
n'est pas la solution pour 40 millions
d'automobilistes c'est déjà prévu par le
texte le président du tribunal
correctionnel à proximité déjà d'annuler
le permis de conduire et la nuit pendant
longtemps ça veut dire que le président
du tribunal correctionnel déjà va se
retrouver démunis d'un certain nombre de
possibilités parce que lui a la
possibilité de renvoyer devant le juge
d'application des peindre avec un suivi
ou un suivi des personnes qui ont été
condamnées ce matin à Roubaix lors de la
cérémonie d'hommage aux trois policiers
tués le président Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas fait d'annonce il a juste dénoncé
les comportements qui tuent
les ravages de ces comportements qui
tuent on en parle ce soir avec mes
invités bonsoir
Harris sabatta kaki vous êtes avocat
spécialisé en droit routier au sein du
cabinet de Caumont tout à fait avec nous
ce soir également Christophe Ramon vous
êtes directeur des études et
porte-parole de l'association Prévention
routières j'accueille à vos côtés
Benjamin Cuques bonsoir vous êtes ce
journaliste spécialiste de l'automobile
et des transports et puis Mathilde
Sirault éditorialiste politique pardon à
Public Sénat qui m'accompagnera tout au
long de cette émission alors je le
disais en annonçant le sommaire de ce
débat plus de 3200 personnes ont trouvé
la mort sur les routes l'an dernier et
parmi elles 700 à cause d'un conducteur
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants on l'a vu
dans le sujet qui vient d'être diffusé
700 tués par an 21% de la mortalité
routière on parlera tout à l'heure des
autres facteurs accidentogènes l'alcool
la vitesse on verra mais je voulais
commencer cette émission sur le problème
de la drogue car c'est un sujet qui a
marqué l'actualité récente d'abord
est-ce que c'est phénomène nouveau où
est-ce qu'on mesure davantage Christophe
Ramon c'est un phénomène qui est assez
ancien il est lié à la consommation de
cannabis notamment et c'est aussi un
phénomène nouveau parce que depuis
quelques années les forces de l'ordre
n'ont plus de moyens de détection
notamment avec des kits salivaires qui
permettent de faire des du dépistage en
bord de route donc ça monte au niveau
judiciaire on a environ 100 000 délits
liés à la consommation de stupéfiants au
volant par an et des kits salivaires
donc c'est un petit coton-tige qu'on met
dans la bouche ça détecte quoi c'est le
gendarme ou le policier qui peut
réaliser ce test
ça marche comme un test covid ou un test
de grossesse
pas vraiment dans on est obligé de se
soumettre aux dépistage
c'est à base d'un réactif en fait qui
permet de voir si une suspicion de
consommation de drogue on détecte je
crois 4 ou 5 types de drogues voilà si
c'est positif il faut faire un deuxième
pré ou une prise de sang qui va
permettre derrière de confirmer de faire
la preuve de de l'infraction je continue
avec vous sur un point est-ce que les
effets de la drogue sont les mêmes que
les effets de l'alcool non ce ne sont
pas les mêmes effets
il y a par exemple le cannabis ça altère
fortement la perception les réflexes
ça mécanisme qui est différent de
l'alcool l'alcool va favoriser des
prises de risques caractérisées par
contre ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
lorsqu'on consomme de l'alcool et de la
drogue ça les effets ne s'annule pas au
contraire se multiplient on a 14 fois
plus de risques de provoquer un accident
mortel c'est ça quand on consomme et de
la drogue et de l'alcool donc si on
consomme uniquement du cannabis et à
russe qui est multiplié par deux ou
trois déjà ici on consomme de l'alcool
en plus voilà le risque est multiplié
par carte 14 voire plus en cas de fortes
consommation d'accord Harris Samata qui
je me tourne vers vous parce que ces
tests salivaires est-ce que c'est
contrôle vous paraît fiable alors ils
sont il y a plusieurs contrôles donc
lorsque l'automobiliste se fait
intercepter la première chose qui est
faite c'est un dépistage salivaire qui
révèle un résultat positif ou négatif si
le résultat est positif l'automobilise
peut-être soumis un prélèvement
cellulaire qui est envoyé en laboratoire
et qui permet d'être plus précis et plus
fiable que le simple test et l'hiver qui
est fait sur le bord de la route mais le
plus précis sur la dose ou la nature de
la drogue sur la nature de la drogue
parce que sur la dose en fait il y a pas
de il y a pas de taux à franchir pour
être sous le coup du délit de conduite
sous l'emprise de stupéfiants donc que
vous soyez juste positif un peu ou
énormément ça ne change rien en gros que
vous ayez fumé un joint où vous ayez un
rail de cocaïne c'est la même chose tout
à fait contrairement à l'alcool qui là
vous avez des taux 0,40
pour ce qui est des stupéfiants et sur
demande de l'automobiliste
une prise de sang peut être effectuée
alors soit d'office mais si
l'automobiliste la demande et c'est
souvent dissuadé par les forces de
l'ordre parce que ça prend du temps de
pratiquer une prise de sang ce qu'il
faut emmener la personne aux urgences et
procéder à la prise de sang et donc
c'est long mais c'est beaucoup plus
fiable parce qu'on peut avoir un taux
grâce à la prise de sang mais dans la
majorité des contrôles c'est simplement
le prélèvement cellulaire qui est
effectué
et la prise de sang permet parfois
d'invalider le test
positif au test et
négative vous ne pouvez pas être
poursuivi pour le délit de conduite
empire de produits stupéfiants et alors
j'ai une question l'alcool on sait que
les effets d'ici peu au bout de quelques
heures peut-être une demi-journée ou une
journée si on a beaucoup beaucoup les
traces de drogue dans l'organisme
longtemps plusieurs semaines ça dépend
du type de drogue donc c'est oui ça peut
être très long c'est à dire que un joint
fumé trois semaines auparavant on peut
être positif au prélèvement salivaires
sur le bord de la route et donc à ce
moment là c'est on obtient un compte
comme une circonstance agrante non le
délit est là prélèvement c'est l'hiver
sur le bord de la route positif ou
stupéfiant rétention du permis de
conduire de l'automobile
parce que c'est puni comme ça comment
c'est puni
à mon sens ou dans les faits dans les
faits et puis ensuite dans les faits la
personne qui est contrôlée positif au
stupéfiant se voit suspendu son permis
dans la plupart des cas il a six points
de retrait à son permis et 135 euros
d'amende alors juste pour qu'on soit
très précis suspendu ça veut dire
qu'elle le récupère tous les trois mois
entre 3 et 6 mois donc
6 points et 135 euros d'amende quel que
soit la nature de la drogue quel que
soit la drogue quel que soit la nature
du de la nature de la drogue sachant
qu'avec une prise de sang un test
salivaire positif peut s'avérer
effectivement négatif à la prise de sang
parce que si on va dans un concert de
reggae par exemple on va
recevoir quelques effluves de de
cannabis sans forcément y avoir goûté de
reggaies ou d'autres styles de musique
ça peut arriver parfois mais le
l'arsenal judiciaire et prévoit beaucoup
plus de choses à commencer par la
suspension de permis qui peut aller
jusqu'à trois ans en fait
l'annulation du permis en cas de
récidive une peine d'intérêt de travail
d'intérêt général des peines de jour
amende l'interdiction de conduire un
véhicule à moteur jusqu'à 5 ans
l'obligation de devoir faire un stage de
sensibilisation à la sécurité routière
ce que j'avais d'une très très grande
utilité mais bon c'est pas grave c'est
prévu l'obligation d'accomplir au frais
du au frais du prévenu des
sensibilisation de sensibilisation sur
les dangers de la drogue toujours est-il
et la confisqueation du véhicule qui
n'est jamais presque jamais parce que ça
ce que vous nous présentez c'est la
palette de sanction de peine prévue
mais et une extension qui est laissée
à l'appréciation du juge sachant que le
juge ne retiens ne retient quasiment
jamais la confiscation du véhicule parce
que
on lui demande dans les dans les
circulaires judiciaires de tenir compte
de la non
désinsertions sociales de ne pas faire
un des inséré social de d'une personne
c'est-à-dire qu'un type qui travaille
qui habite dans la banlieue de Verdun
qui bosse à Verdun je donne un endroit
qui est pas très bien desserré par les
transports il se fait contrôler à
l'alcool ou au cannabis on pourrait tout
à fait le juge pour voilà votre Twingo
votre CLIO par à la vente elle sera
vendu parler de domaine au prix de
l'encan et ça et c'est terminé pour vous
vous la paierez à crédit vous finir de
payer le crédit dessus mais c'est plus
notre problème sauf que on va expliquer
que dans l'intérêt de la société faut
pas fabriquer quelqu'un en exclus social
qui de soi qui devrait faire du vélo ou
qui serait contraint de payer un crédit
sur quatre ans sur sa voiture donc on va
lui laisser sa voiture donc la peine est
automatiquement minorée et on a vu hier
par exemple la trappe que la jeune femme
qui aime pas son premier joint a quand
même renversé une petite fille qu'elle a
tué Christophe Ramon sont les mêmes
sanctions que pour l'alcool
sont à peu près les mêmes sanctions il y
a il y a aussi des sanctions aggraver
quand il y a consommation à la fois
d'alcool et de drogues et quand il y a
homicide évidemment et quand il y a des
blessures suite à un accident
effectivement les sanctions sont
aggravées donc ça c'est l'arsenal
juridique après c'est effectivement le
ce qui peut poser problème c'est à la
fois l'application de ces sanctions qui
peuvent être plus ou moins laxistes et
puis aussi c'est peut-être le nombre de
contrôles sur les bords de route faire
en sorte que les conducteurs se sentent
surveillés à un impact fort sur la
manière dont on gère la consommation de
drogue ou d'alcool vis-à-vis de la
conduite alors on vient de décrire tout
l'arsenal législatif qui qui existent en
tout cas répressif et pour beaucoup de
Français cela ne suffit pas il faudrait
changer la loi écouter par exemple le
chef Yannick aléno qui a perdu son fils
l'an dernier percuté par un chauffard
dans une voiture volée sous l'emprise
d'alcool et de stupéfiants il était ce
matin l'invité de BFM TV
à domicile routier c'est quoi
c'est un individu qui consomme de la
drogue et de l'alcool au-delà des seuils
autorisés par la loi donc là jusqu'à
présent personne ne les a forcé à se
droguer ni à boire d'accord
ensuite c'est ce même individu rentre
dans son véhicule personne le force à
rentrer dans son véhicule ensuite c'est
individu tourne la clé de son véhicule
et démarre personne ne force à partir et
puis
sous l'emprise stupéfiant
voilà il tape quelqu'un et il le tue et
moi je suis désolé à partir du moment où
on décide décisionnaire de se dire on
n'est pas dans le cas de figure de
quelqu'un qui était blouillé par le
soleil quoi alors Yannick et Neno dit
qu'il ne veut plus qu'on parle
d'homicide involontaire mais domicile
routier ça changeait quoi au-delà de ces
mots qui sont importants et aussi
symboliques pour pour les familles
notamment des victimes ça changerait pas
grand chose à part la sémantique mais
qui est très importante
mais mise à part la sémantique de
qualifier l'homicide inventaire en
homicide routier
les deux propositions de loi une au
scénario une à l'Assemblée nationale ne
prévoit pas d'aggraver les sanctions
encourues c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
vous rappelez juste au téléspectateurs
il y a deux propositions de loi qui ont
été déposées effectivement une au Sénat
une à l'Assemblée pour créer ce délit
qui n'existe pas d'homicide routier
Gérald Darmanin est d'ailleurs assez
d'accord avec ce terme de domicile
routier mais qui aurait été alors là
sémantique est importante parce que dans
le mot involontaire les familles qui se
qui voit le meurtrier le de leur fils de
leur fille avoir
poursuivi pour un délit qualifié
d'inventaire ça peut paraître surprenant
et ça ça peut être difficilement la
volontaire pour prendre de la drogue ou
de l'alcool on est toujours volontaire
pour prendre sa voiture pour la démarrer
la personne qui fait ça elle est pas
volontaire de tuer la personne qu'elle
aura tué au final oui sauf que à ce
moment là on pourrait les juges ont
retenu que madame sarahimie avait été
assassiné par Monsieur Traoré parce
qu'il avait pris de la même cadre on
rappelle c'était
on a retenu l'altération du discernement
si vous voulez vous prenez une voiture
vous défoncez vous défoncez au cannabis
avant vous prenez une voiture vous
percutez quatre personnes vous dites
altération du discernement à un moment
il y a la responsabilité individuelle en
amont c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
exonérer les gens de leur responsabilité
intellectuelle on sait que la consommer
de la drogue en France c'est interdit il
y a des pays où ça ne l'est pas mais en
France c'est interdit à partir du moment
où on sait que c'est interdit on ne
prend pas son volant derrière on ne
prend pas son on ne prend pas son
autobial après avoir consommé de la
drogue ou de l'alcool point il y a une
espèce de on est on est en France une
espèce de tolérance vis-à-vis parce
qu'on a tous un beau-frère on a tous un
oncle j'ai un oncle moi qui s'est fait
choper à 500 mètres de chez lui en train
de voilà contrôle routier bah il avait
bu
attention de permis 135 euros d'amende 6
points ma mère qui me dit son frère qui
me dit a quand même ils ont été vache il
était il était à 500 mètres de chez lui
j'ai remis si dans les 500 mètres il
percutait quelqu'un ça n'a évidemment
aucun rapport c'est évidemment aucun
rapport et donc à un moment il y a le
discernement et le l'altération du
gouvernement mais on doit considérer
surtout qu'il y a pas d'altération de
libre arbitre avant de commencer alors
juste une chose dans les propositions de
loi et notamment dans celle de
l'assemblée il est prévu de rétablir des
peines planchées minimum ça c'est une
différence avec la situation actuelle
puisque en cas de
condamnation et une peine ferme
l'objet de la loi et que les personnes
aient réellement en prison parce que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
peines qui sont prononcées pour des
homicides inventaires aggravés par les
par l'alcool par les stupéfiants vous
allez rarement en prison bon alors le
ministre de l'Intérieur voudrait aussi
enlever on l'a dit un 12 points retirer
le permis illico pour toute personne qui
conduit alors qu'il a consommé de la
drogue Éric Ciotti le patron des
républicains proposent lui d'annuler le
permis pour plusieurs années on a
l'impression qu'il y a plus de sévérité
sur la drogue que sur l'alcool
dans les propos qui sont tenus parce que
là l'actualité le veut peut-être après
c'est des sanctions qui sont
relativement du même acabit il y a
d'autres mesures aussi en propose pas de
retirer le permis pour 12 points pour
pour l'alcool c'est que pour la drogue
dans les déclarations publiques des élus
ce serait la perte du permis direct la
validité du permis
pour ça il faut qu'il y ait contre des
contrôles quoi en bord de route il faut
avoir le sentiment de pouvoir être
contrôlé
lorsqu'on sort lors d'une soirée ou même
en journée puisque on consomme des
notamment du cannabis dans la journée il
faut vraiment qu'ils sentiment de
pouvoir être contrôlant la peur du
gendarme voilà et globalement il y a
moins de dépistage de drogue sur les
bords de route que d'alcool les
pistaches d'alcool bien environ 10
millions par an en France c'est déjà pas
énorme par rapport à 40 millions de
automobilistes et les tests de dépistage
de des drogues sont beaucoup plus cher
parce que toutes les brigades de
gendarmerie tout les policiers n'en sont
pas équipés
et donc elles vont les utiliser elles
vont les utiliser à bon escient donc les
forces de l'ordre des policiers des
gendarmes soient habitués à détecter des
signes de suspicion par exemple
lorsqu'on ouvre la fenêtre s'il y a de
l'odeur une odeur de cannabis bon c'est
une indication importante les locutions
la démarche des personnes
vendredi soir ou les samedis soirs
utiliser quand ils ont une petite
suspicion de de consommation ou alors de
manière systématique après des accidents
mais comme on a beaucoup entendu parler
dans les médias justement de drames
d'accident ces derniers mois est-ce que
ça ça a changé quelque part la
jurisprudence c'est ce qu'on peut déjà
l'analyser ou est-ce que c'est un petit
peu tôt et est-ce que les contrôles sont
davantage important enfin est-ce que ça
a créé une prise une prise en compte en
moyenne je crois qu'on est contrôlé une
fois tous les 8 ans sur la route si vous
voulez
[Musique]
j'ai fait 30 000 km par an en faisant
des essais pour un grand quotidien
pendant 10 ans le je faisais un essai
toutes les semaines j'ai été contrôlé
deux fois durant la période pendant 10
ans et je faisais 30 000 km par an en
moyenne on doit y contrôler ouais je
vous dis tous les 8 ans sur la routine
et j'habite en j'habite en Île-de-France
en même temps une petite cour où il y a
pas beaucoup de contrôle à Paris on
n'est jamais contrôlé Harry ça va takake
les juges sont-ils plus sévères pour
reprendre la question de machines et les
contrôles plus fréquents non moi j'ai
pas noté de jugement plus sévère ces
derniers ces dernières semaines
je reviens sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure
on essaye de d'amande c'est pas 130 €
d'amende 135 euros d'amende c'est pas un
excès de vitesse ou un feu rouge ou un
stop la peine les peines en moyenne qui
sont prononcés par les tribunaux plutôt
entre 400 et 1000 euros ce qu'on voit
dans la plupart des jugements qui sont
prononcés
les suspensions
en effet trois six mois lorsque c'est la
première fois mais en matière de
récidive aujourd'hui le récidiviste
alcool stupéfiant et c'est considéré
d'ailleurs comme la même chose au niveau
de la récidive il encourt l'annulation
automatique de son permis qui peut aller
jusqu'à trois ans c'est rarement le cas
c'est souvent six mois huit mois un an
d'annulation de permis
mais par contre c'est confiscation
obligatoire du véhicule si le véhicule
lui appartient
lorsqu'on est en récidive
c'est une peine automatique
c'est-à-dire que le véhicule ne vous
appartient plus il est vendu au profit
de l'État en matière du récit c'est
automatique vous abordez la question de
si on en est propriétaire si on est
propriétaire tout à fait et vous en tant
qu'avocat je sais que bon c'est votre
métier et c'est très bien vous la
plupart des avocats dans le délire
routier plaide le fait que la plupart
des véhicules 50% des véhicules
aujourd'hui sont en leasing c'est à dire
que si vous achetez une belle berline
allemande qui va très vite voilà la
partie professionnelle concessionnaire
en théorie
en location longue durée pour 36 ou 48
mois
or le le code pénal l'article 131 21 du
code pénal prévoit que le juge est tout
à fait libre de saisir tout bien qui
conclure qui conclure qui concourt
pardon à la commission d'une infraction
pénale c'est-à-dire que si vous êtes au
volant d'une voiture que vous avez en
leasing où vous avez pris emprunté à
votre beau-frère et mais qui est qui est
une grosse grosse voiture très sportive
et que vous roulez à 80 avec du shit
plein de nez comme on peut l'imaginer là
aujourd'hui vous vous retrouvez à dire
ben non mais la voiture elle est pas à
moi donc on me l'a saisi pas mais le
juge pourrait tout à fait saisir il le
fait pas il le fait pas mais alors qu'il
pourrait dire bah écoutez maintenant
vous avez vous êtes emmerdé vous allez
voir 80 000 € de crédit remboursé auprès
de BMW Audi ou Mercedes Christophe Ramon
l'alcool au volant ça baisse pas
la part des accidents mortels à l'alcool
et relativement stable comment ça
s'explique parce que peut-être les
mesures sont pas assez ciblées sur cette
ce type de d'infraction de de conduite à
risque et notamment mon association
réclame la généralisation des
éthylotests anti-démarrage sur les
véhicules ça existe déjà sur les
autocars tous les chauffeurs de car le
matin avant de prendre leur service
souffle dans l'appareil pour pouvoir
démarrer le véhicule ça existe de plus
en plus dans les procédures judiciaires
c'est à dire on permet à certains
conducteurs de revenir à la conduite à
condition d'être équipé d'un appareil
qui les empêche de démarrer en cas de
consommation d'alcool et c'est vraiment
très efficace quand le véhicule est
équipé c'est très développé dans des
pays comme les États-Unis la basse et
soit vous avez cet appareil là soit vous
allez en prison donc c'est très bon vous
seriez pour la généralisation de ce type
de dispositif sur tous les véhicules de
séries alors c'est une action près de
l'Europe ça vient petit à petit mais
vraiment très lentement dans une
première étape ça va être rendu possible
c'est à dire que les il y aura un prêt
câblage dans les véhicules qui frappe on
pourra installer en rétrofit le véhicule
d'un éthylotest anti-démarrage les
réticences elles viennent des
constructeurs où elles viennent plutôt
des politiques tout un ensemble
notamment même la Commission européenne
avait des doutes sur le l'efficacité en
terme de coûts bénéfices de la mesure
alors que l'enjeu est vraiment
considérable en terme de devis à sauver
oui vous direz
sur ce que vous dites en effet c'est une
différence entre l'alcool et stupéfiant
pour une suspension on parle pour une
première fois en autobus fait arrêter
pour une première fois il a six mois de
suspension imaginons de suspension de la
préfecture ce qu'il y a toujours la
sanction administrative qui arrive dans
un premier temps et ensuite la sanction
judiciaire au tribunal qui vient
compléter avec l'amende le retrait de
points et l'annulation confiscation etc
bon
l'éthylotest en cinéma j'ai proposé aux
automobilistes lorsque c'est une
première fois avec leur taux ne dépasse
pas les 0,7080 mg par litre et c'est une
très bonne chose puisque
primoine bon il y a comme une erreur
on parle pas de récidiviste on parle
simplement de Primo délinquants et la
mesure peut être prolongée au tribunal
et même imposer au conducteur pour
pouvoir reprendre le volant pour les
stupéfiants
aucun aménagement possible là pour le
coup vous avez une suspension c'est une
suspension ferme et aucun aménagement
possible alors on est à peu près la
moitié des pages je voudrais qu'on ouvre
un autre chapitre maintenant sur la sur
la vitesse parce que Mathilde on a
l'impression d'avoir parfois un peu un
gouvernement schizophrène ou en
exécotisme schizophrène dur dans les
mots contre ces comportements
inacceptables et responsables qui tuent
comme dirait le président et en même
temps quand il s'agit de drogue au
volant mais plus clément avec les excès
de vitesse quand ils sont légers quand
ils se sont des petits excès de vitesse
quelques jours après la réforme de
retraite le ministre de l'Intérieur a
assoupli les sanctions pour les petits
excès de vitesse
jour précisément à l'après la
promulgation de ce texte des retraites
si contestés Gérald Darmanin est
intervenu pour annoncer qu'en cas
d'excès de vitesse inférieure à 5 km/h
il n'y aurait plus de retrait de points
sur le permis de conduire une mesure qui
vise à arrêter d'emmerder les Français
selon la formule consacrée et qui
s'inscrit plus généralement dans une
offensive du gouvernement visant à
gommer tous les irritants du quotidien
pour faire donc politiquement oublier
cet épisode douloureux des retraites et
au nom de la politique du bon sens comme
l'expliquait le ministre de l'Intérieur
le 20 avril
on rajoute les quelques kilomètres à
l'heure que les Français trouvaient
extrêmement frustrant considérant qu'on
le retirait beaucoup trop de points le
retirant parfois le permis de conduire
les empêchant pour les grands
utilisateurs de la route notamment ceux
qui travaillaient qu'ils aient beaucoup
de kilomètres le matin ou le soir qui
passait devant beaucoup de retard
automatique et qui pouvait légitimement
se dire que cette politique n'était pas
une politique de bon sens nous leur
permettons évidemment de pouvoir arrêter
ces retraits de points qui les agacés et
qui n'étaient pas très cohérent au petit
de sécurité routière et que seule la
France à peu près appliquée dans ces
conditions
donc on le voit bien le patron de Bovo
s'adresse prioritairement assez français
qui doivent démarrer leur voiture pour
aller travailler en tout ces petits
excès de vitesse inférieurs à 5 km/h il
représentait jusqu'ici 60% des retraites
points donc ce sont les chiffres de Bobo
ce qui contraignait souvent les
automobilistes sanctionnés à devoir
effectuer des fameux stages de
récupération de points alors c'est vrai
que c'est intervenu après la forme de
retraite il en avait déjà quand même
parlé un peu toujours dans les bons
moments vous vous souvenez au moment des
législatives en fait ce que dit Gérald
Darmanin c'est que ça revient à quel
gentil avec les gentils comme ils le
disait à propos de sa loi sur
l'immigration et oui gentil avec les
gentils et donc méchant avec les
méchants puisque on en a parlé Gérald
Darmanin affiche en même temps sa
fermeté pour ce qu'il appelle les
délinquants de la route les sanctions on
en a parlé sont durcis en cas de
consommation de stupéfiants
politiquesment pour le ministre cette
évolution sur les sur les petits excès
de vitesse cet assouplissement des
sanctions est évidemment favorable
puisqu'elle est bien vue dans l'opinion
elle lui permet à peu de frais de
sculpter cette image d'homme politique
proche des préoccupations des Français
tenant d'une droite plutôt populaire
pendant la crise sanitaire on s'en
souvient Gérald Darmanin c'était déjà
montré assez réticent à l'idée de devoir
encourager les préfets à effectuer des
contrôles sur la question du respect des
couvre-feu des mesures sanitaires
certains appelleront ça être gentil avec
les gentils donc peut-être de la
démagogie la vitesse ça reste pourtant
un facteur accidentogène important c'est
un thème central de ce qu'on appelle le
système sûr en fait puisque la vitesse
non seulement la vitesse est une cause
d'accident environ 30% des accidents
sont liés une vitesse excessive ou
inadaptées mais surtout la vitesse c'est
un facteur de gravité c'est-à-dire plus
on va vite quelques kilomètres heures de
plus font qu'une blessure légère
devienne blessure grave ou une blessure
grave devient un décès donc il y a
vraiment c'est vraiment un facteur très
important qui
qui implique non seulement les
comportements et c'est pour ça que cette
mesure peut avoir des conséquences
malheureuses sur le nombre d'accidents
de la route oui on le déplore puisque le
en fait le point qu'on va perdre
si on ne reconnaît pas une nouvelle
infraction dans la Simon on va le
récupérer donc il y a un caractère
pédagogique qui incite à se tenir
vraiment exemplaire pendant 6 mois on a
l'assiette on est certes on n'est pas
content parce qu'on a perdu un point
mais au bout de six mois on est content
parce qu'on le récupère du fait de pas
avoir commis d'infraction donc il y a il
y a aussi le côté carotte dans la mesure
donc ça c'est dommage de de d'abandonner
cette mesure et puis aussi on le voit
sur les dernières années on a grignoté
les 80 km/h sur les routes
départementales qui sont les routes les
plus dangereuses
il y a tout un tas de mesures qui vont
dans le mauvais sens dans le mauvais
sens alors même que la France a engagé à
diviser par deux le nombre de tués de
blessés graves d'ici 2030 et que la
réduction de vitesse ça marche plutôt en
tout cas si on en croit Grégory douce et
le maire de Lyon qui a limité la majeure
partie de ces voix à 30 km/h écoutez
Lyon rejoint de ce fait et bien toutes
les grandes villes européennes Bruxelles
les villes espagnoles néerlandaises
Paris etc qui ont déjà fait le choix du
30 km/h et qui ont déjà démontré
chiffres à la pluie qu'effectivement on
avait en moyenne entre 40 et 50% de
morts en moins et de blesser grave sur
les routes donc c'est important grâce à
cette mesure on va sauver des vies donc
priorité à la santé et à la sécurité des
lyonnaises et des Lyonnais vous voulez
réagir rejoins scandaleux cette
démagogie anti vitesse sur la route les
limitations actuelles de vitesse de 90
730 km/h ont été établis en 74 vous
étiez au volant d'une Renault 16 en 74
c'était pas fou en termes de freinage en
termes de sécurité même la meilleure BMW
ou Mercedes sont plus sourd aujourd'hui
mais ça fait toujours aussi mal
sauf que si vous prenez un mur à 130
km/h sur l'autoroute ou à 180 km/h sur
l'autoroute je vous rassure le résultat
sera exactement le même au-delà d'une
certaine vitesse au-delà 130 le résultat
est le même on meurt il y a une réalité
c'est que le même la voiture la plus
solide du monde est résisterait pas à
des vitesses importantes très
importantes en revanche la mesure de de
Gérard de Gérald de Darmanin on sait où
elle est scandaleuse c'est de dire on
retire le petit point mais le petit
point sur autoroute on pourrait router à
150 sur autoroute je vous dis sans
problème 150/60 ça poserait pas de
problème c'est même la vitesse d'une
Twingo aujourd'hui le ça poserait aucun
problème ce n'est pas sur les autoroutes
qui est le plus d'accidents aux abords
d'une école aux abords d'une ville dans
une ville le petit point c'est 5 km/h
au-dessus si vous êtes à 40 35 km/h
devant une école et que vous percutez un
enfant c'est pas la même chose qu'à 25
c'est là où c'est criminels de rouler à
plus de 30 km/h en ville les
Britanniques on disait en préparant
cette émission une voiture c'est une
arme par destination je prenais tout à
l'heure
on pourrait brider les moteurs voilà une
idée de faire avec les voitures
électriques c'est-à-dire que les
voitures électriques les plus puissantes
aujourd'hui elle dépasse pas les 180
km/h c'est à dire que parce que avec une
courbe de vitesse ça sert pardon je vais
poser une question de béotien et Dieu
sait que j'aime courir à quoi ça sert
une voiture qui va à 186430 ça fait
plaisir c'est l'impression de la
puissance et le sentiment de puissance
de viril
mais surtout anthropologique
absolument mais prenons un exemple assez
concret c'est le Royaume-Uni exactement
le même la même population que la France
70 millions d'habitants
l'angle sur les routes c'est 140 150
dans certaines voies ça il y a deux en
ville c'est 35 km/h partout 20 miles et
par contre sur les routes secondaires
c'est 100 km heure et pas 80 et 1800
morts par an sur les routes la moitié la
moitié parce que il y a des radars
partout qui rigolent pas les gens ont
des consignes ont été bien éduqués c'est
à dire que si on est trois sorties il y
en a un qui boit pas même si on est deux
il y en a un qui boit pas et cet effort
là n'a pas été fait tous ces efforts de
pédagogie d'éducation même plus que
pédagogie la pédagogie c'est pour les
petits enfants de 7 ans mais d'éducation
à la route chez les jeunes gens n'a pas
été fait il y a pas assez de
complaisance en Grande-Bretagne
vis-à-vis de la drogue à part dans
certains films comme Trainspotting
tandis qu'on a pas le côté c'est sympa
de fumer du shit et voilà et là le
résultat
on a deux fois moins de mort en
Grande-Bretagne qu'en France rapidement
Harry sabattataki sur ce sujet il était
nécessaire pour vous ce geste de
une bonne une bonne chose parce que
quand on parle de là on parle d'un excès
de vitesse entre 1 et 4 km/h au-dessus
de la vitesse autorisée donc on est
plutôt sur la faute d'inattention que
sur la contravention parce que ça fait
que redécaler la prochaine fois de
d'inattention qui sera encore plus haute
oui mais bon 4 km au dessus on parlait
juste avant d'alcool de super héros
volants il y a quand même de la marge
entre tout ça et je rappelle que entre 5
et 9 km/heure au dessus de la vitesse
autorisée vous perdez toujours un point
et entre 1 et 4 au dessus l'amande est
toujours
encore eu et juste pour terminer
là-dessus vous disiez vous non vous
disiez il y a un on perd un point 6 mois
plus tard on le récupère quand on est
chauffeur routier quand on est qu'on est
chauffeur taxi c'est pas un point tous
les six mois c'est plusieurs points
qu'on risque de perdre pour défaut
d'inattention quand on est toute la
journée on parle pas très
attentifs
c'est de l'inattention la vitesse on va
continuer d'en parler parce que c'est
quand même un sujet assez inflammable on
le sait politiquement on se souvient de
l'affaire des 80 km/h et on va en parler
avec Tam Tran lui l'abaissement de la
vitesse bonsoir Tam bon l'abaissement de
la vitesse à 80 km/h sur la route
secondaire c'est un sujet qui avait
mobilisé très tôt les sénateurs et oui
on va avoir décembre
2015 la mesure n'est pas
encore debout le porte-voix de la grogne
des automobilistes et des territoires
c'est l'ex sénateur les républicains
Michel Raison face à lui un ex-ministre
également Christophe Castaner alors aux
Relations avec le Parlement et qui porte
la ligne Édouard Philippe regardez
vous ne pouvez pas vous baser uniquement
sur ce précepte italien qui va piano va
sano si vous mettez ça en place au mois
de janvier comment vous allez expliquer
quels arguments aux citoyens merci les
études montrent que baisser de 10% de 10
km/h sur les routes bidirectionnelles
sont séparateurs central permettrait de
sauver 350 vies par an on peut décider
d'avoir du courage politique pour sauver
des vies et voilà qui ne convainc
absolument pas les sénateurs pas plus
qui des janvier février janvier 2018 se
regroupe sur des groupes facebook du nom
de colère des groupes qui donneront lieu
ensuite au mouvement des gilets jaunes
il Sénat décide alors de lancer lui
aussi un groupe mais un groupe de
travail sur la sécurité routière avec le
même Michel Raison avec deux autres
sénateurs associalistes une centriste et
au bout de deux mois d'études ils
remettent un rapport un rapport qui
préconise de décentraliser la décision
pour eux c'est au département de décider
s'il faut abaisser la vitesse à 80 km/h
ou pas c'est à eux d'identifier les
routes et les tronçons accidentogènes ou
l'abaissement de la vitesse est utile et
là encore le contexte compte bien sûr
puisqu'on est en plein grand débat
Emmanuel Macron s'est déclaré favorable
à des aménagements de cette loi les 80
km/h sont devenus un symbole de la
déconnexion de l'exécutif et tout cela
finit par aboutir dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités en décembre
2019 à les modifier par le Sénat elle
donne bien au président de département
au préfet le pouvoir de relever la
vitesse à 90 une décision qui est
applaudi dès demain par les associations
comme 40 millions d'automobilistes le
bilan des courses et bien c'est la
grande marche arrière depuis près de la
moitié des départements sont repassés au
90 km/h au moins sur une partie de leur
réseau rapidement c'est un traumatisme
cette affaire des 80 km/h pour les
études ça reste effectivement une mesure
qui est décrié par beaucoup de
proches d'Emmanuel Macron et de
ministres surtout des élus locaux qui
avait un ancrage vraiment local et qui
avait senti la grogne que ça pouvait
susciter dans la population
et ça a donné lieu à une réflexion aussi
sur le mode d'application de certaines
de certaines règles de façon uniforme
sur le territoire on voit que voilà il y
a davantage de de différenciation et
depuis cet épisode je voudrais qu'on
termine cette émission en ce penchant
sur un autre facteur d'accident dont on
parle plus rarement c'est l'histoire de
Pauline Déroulède vous savez numéro 1
française de tennis fauteuil elle a été
victime d'un accident de la route en
2018 le conducteur était un homme de 92
ans il avait confondu la de frein
avec celle de l'accélérateur et Pauline
des relais midi maintenant pour faire
évoluer la loi sur le contrôle régulier
du permis de conduire regardez depuis 3
ans je me bats pour qu'il y ait des
visites médicales obligatoires pour tous
les conducteurs avec une fréquence plus
régulière à partir d'un certain âge j'ai
lancé une campagne de sécurité routière
pour sensibiliser le plus grand nombre
le plus large public et aussi évidemment
les pouvoirs publics le gouvernement
avec qui je travaille actuellement pour
que la loi évolue et qu'on puisse
repasser des tests d'aptitude à la
conduite tout au long de notre vie et
éviter des drames comme comme mon
accident parce qu'il y en a encore
beaucoup trop
Christophe Ramond et mesures d'âge sur
le permis de conduire c'est une bonne
idée ça existe dans pas mal de pays en
Europe en fait il y a deux modes le mode
français ou on va cibler les contrôles
puisque quand même un système de
contrôle de l'aptitude au volant avec
des médecins agréés par les préfectures
et des certains pays mettent en place
des visites médicales ou des
questionnaires de santé donc il y a
toutes nos plateformes certains liés à
l'âge d'autres pas donc la tendance
actuelle au niveau européen c'est de
remonter l'âge minimum à partir duquel
on peut faire ces contrôles liés à l'âge
vraiment donc en fait ce qui arrive en
France le plus souvent c'est que c'est
sur les compagnies d'assurance qui
refusent à partir d'un certain âge je
vous assurer et surtout on s'est aperçu
au niveau européen que les pays qui
mettent en place ces mesures ils ont pas
de il y a pas de bénéfice en termes
d'accident en fait
les seniors arrêtent de conduire un peu
trop d'ailleurs se présente pas aux
visites médicales du coup arrête la
conduite vont se déplacer autrement et
donc ils sont passagers ils sont plus
responsable que ça des accidents c'est
ce que vous voulez souligner en fait il
y a un report du risque on va être
passager d'un conducteur plus jeune donc
on aura un risque d'accident qui sera
aussi important on va circuler peut-être
à vélo
comme au Pays-Bas ou dans d'autres pays
et le risque d'accidents il est quand
même important donc en fait le bénéfice
elle n'a jamais été démontré c'est bien
le problème par contre certains pays
mettent en place des mesures vraiment
qui permettent de cibler uniquement les
personnes qui ont un vrai besoin de
d'analyse notamment par le biais de
questionnaire voilà et en France on a un
système voilà qui qui implique le
conducteur de se présenter à ses visites
médicales vous êtes opposés à risque ça
va t'attaquer pas forcément mais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui les seuls visites
médicales qui existent c'est lorsque
vous avez fait l'objet d'une rétention
et d'une suspension de permis pour
vitesse alcool ou stupéfiants pour
pouvoir récupérer votre permis de
conduire à l'issue de la mesure de
suspension vous êtes obligé de vous
soumettre à des tests psychotechniques
en fonction de la durée de votre
suspension annulation de permis puis à
une visite médicale c'est un médecin
agressif c'est un excès de vitesse ou en
commission médicale et ça c'est un peu
le stade de tue lorsque c'est de
l'alcool et des stupéfiants bon c'est le
système actuel
il est pas si mauvais Benjamin quick
pour finir avec vous Jacques Chirac
avait fait de la sécurité routière une
grande cause présidentielle est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que que 20 ans
plus tard le sujet est aussi important
aussi prioritaire dans le développement
public 20 ans plus tard je pense que la
cause de la sécurité routière est
totalement abandonnée réellement
réellement totalement abandonné on le
voit avec la mesure des 1 km/h des 5
km/h de Gérald de Darmanin on le voit
avec le prix du permis de conduire qui
est absolument aucune solution pour des
gens qui sont en province qui sont dans
des communes rurales qui ont absolument
besoin d'un permis de conduire ça coûte
aujourd'hui un permis de conduire faut
pas se mentir ça coûte entre 1200 et
1500 euros et le passé c'est
que ça favorise le fait que des gens qui
n'en ont pas les moyens prennent une
voiture sans permis il y a des il y a
des cas comme ça ça favorise le fait que
quand on va faire un apport on va même
si ça nous a coûté cher on va pas
forcément prendre soin malheureusement
il y a des il y a pas d'éducation du
tout à la route il y a pas du tout
d'éducation pas la route dans les dans
les lycées il y a pas d'éducation à la
route il y a une espèce de mode en plus
ces derniers temps mais qui est très
parisienne c'est à dire de dire les
jeunes ne veulent plus passer le permis
les jeunes ne s'intéressent plus aux
voitures les jeunes ne veut plus passer
le permis c'est complètement faux parce
que bon c'est peut-être vrai quand on
habite entre le 4e et le 8e
arrondissement de Paris ou peut-être
juste même dans les arrondissements
intra-muros dès qu'on sort en banlieue
en 3e couronne si on a pas de permis on
est pendule c'est le c'est le il faut
intervie de conduire mais c'est pas la
trottinette qui va vous emmener de
Cergy-Pontoise à Versailles ou à Trappes
facilement quoi c'est vous partagez le
sentiment c'est une cause qui est le
sentiment d'ailleurs ça se ressent dans
les chiffres depuis 10 ans le les
statistiques des accidents stagne alors
que une baissait régulièrement depuis le
début des années 70 après c'est pas que
le rôle du gouvernement de l'État c'est
c'est le rôle de toutes les parties
prenantes c'est les entreprises c'est
les établissements scolaires les
enseignants c'est les associations c'est
les conducteurs les piétons les
cyclistes de s'emparer cette question
faire en sorte que cette prévention soit
participative on a besoin de remobiliser
tout le monde puisque les on est on
devrait avoir une vision zéro c'est à
dire faire en sorte que tous les
accidents graves ou mortels soient des
choses inacceptables merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui se
termine donc